[Music]
claps of thunder and flashes of
lightning illuminate a swelling sea as a
ship buckles beneath the waves this is
no ordinary school but a violent and
vengeful tempest and it sets the stage
for Shakespeare's most enigmatic play as
the skies clear we're invited into a
world that seems far removed from our
own but is rife with familiar concerns
about freedom power and control The
Tempest is set on a desert island
exposed to the elements
and ruled with magic and might by
Prospero the exiled Duke of Milan
betrayed by his brother Antonio Prospero
has been marooned on the island for 12
years with his daughter Miranda and his
beloved books in this time he's learnt
the magic of the island and uses it to
harness its elementary spirits he also
rules over the islands only earthly
inhabitant the dejected and demonized
Caliban but after years of plotting
revenge prosperous foe is finally in
sight with the help of the fluttering
sprite Ariel
the magician destroys his brothers ship
and washes its sailors ashore Prospero
x' plotting even extends to his
daughters love life whom he plans to
fall for stranded prince ferdinand and
as Prospero and Ariel close in on
Antonio Caliban joins forces with some
drunken sailors who had a comic plot to
take the island the place stripped
society down to its basest desires with
each faction in hot pursuit of power be
it Overland other people or their own
destiny but Shakespeare knows that power
is always a moving target and as he
reveals these characters dark histories
we begin to wonder if this vicious cycle
will ever end
although Prospero was wronged by Antonio
he has long inflicted his own abuses on
the island hoarding its magical
properties and natural resources for
himself
Caliban especially resents this takeover
the son of sicker acts a witch who
previously ruled the island he initially
helped the exiled find their footing but
he since become their slave and rants
with furious regret and then I loved
thee and showed the all the qualities of
the Isle the fresh Springs brine pits
barren place and fertile cursed bi that
did so with his thunderous language and
seething anger
Caliban constantly reminds Prospero of
what came before this islands mine by
Sycorax my mother which thou takest from
run yet sick rocks also abused the
island an imprisoned area until Prospero
released him now Ariel spends the play
hoping to repay his debt and earn his
freedom while Caliban is enslaved
indefinitely or at least as long as
Prospero is in charge for these reasons
and many more The Tempest has often been
read as an exploration of colonialism
and the moral dilemmas that come with
Encounters of brave new worlds questions
of agency and justice hangover the play
is Caliban the rightful master of the
land will Ariel subtle free and is
Prospero the mighty overseer or is there
some deeper magic at work beyond any one
characters grasp throughout the play
Ariel constantly reminds Prospero of the
freedom he is owed but the question
lingers of whether the invader will be
able to relinquish his grip the question
of ending one's reign is particularly
potent given that The Tempest is
believed to be Shakespeare's final play
in many ways Prospero's actions echo
that of the great entertainer himself
who hatched elaborate plots maneuvered
those around him and cast a spell over
characters and audiences
but by the end of his grand performance
of power and control prosperous final
lines see him humbled by his audience
and the power that they hold over his
creations with the help of your good
hands
gentle breath of yours my sales must
fill or else my project fails which was
too pleased this evokes Shakespeare's
own role as the great entertainer who
surrenders himself ultimately to our
applause one way that Shakespeare
entertained his audiences was with his
clever and cutting insults learn how to
diss someone with style by watching this
video more of a lover than a fighter
find out more with this video
[Music]